two oh hello there
thanks for clicking on this video i
don't know thanks to hell yeah
thanks to ev welcome to the hp podcast
i'm by myself today
good luck ethan uh i'm gonna need it
today it's a lot
more awkward without either being here
because i could do something i couldn't
be like right
and it should be like right but now
it's just me and it's cold
it's raining outside
um ela is with peace and love she has
too much to do
she cannot she cannot make it on
wednesdays anymore
peace and love thank you thank you but
she will be here on friday so
peace and love today's episode is
sponsored by
literally nobody so why don't you head
on over to
uh teddyfresh.com see if there's
anything you like there or
follow us on teddyfresh on instagram
i had to buy that from somebody for ten
thousand dollars with peace and love
the guy who owned the teddy fresh
instagram was squatting on it for so
long
milking me like a
like a horse breeder
it's been a topic of uh great contention
that
horse semen is the most expensive fluid
in the world
a lot of talk about horse even anyway
peace and love
teddy fresh all right i actually googled
it and uh
is that true i i don't think it is well
what's more expensive what's more
valuable than horses
there was a list of the top 10 most
valuable liquids in the world and horse
semen was not on the list it wasn't even
on there
oh so then david stole bad facts from us
right
which makes it even funnier what are the
most valuable liquids
uh top most valuable because
how what could be more expensive than
horses because you have to pay like
like some people pay like half a milli
just for one load of like seabiscuit
yeah is one of them
scorpion venom uh wait why what do
people do with scorpion venom
uh horseshoe crab blood apparently what
the [ __ ]
you say yeah it's used in a lot of uh
it's all like witchcraft [ __ ]
i don't know i think it's like vaccines
king cobra venom
is a 153 000 per gallon
wait why are people using scorpion venom
okay here i have a message
the protein found in scorpion venom can
be used to treat pain in humans
suffering from
ms is that for real or is that like
is that like pseudo science like
homeopathy [ __ ]
uh no i i imagine it's real holy [ __ ] i
gotta
start harvesting squirrels i gotta grow
some scorpions
so wait read that i'm fascinated by this
go ahead read more
uh there's king cobra venom uh
chanel number five is on this list
that's just something i mean this is
just some [ __ ] clickbait website this
could be totally
i mean i don't know i'm still holding on
what are you holding out for horses yeah
your research you would research the
earth's semen uh
how much how much was it per gallon
when we did that i don't know you don't
know that was ben shapiro that wasn't me
oh that's true that was much better
all right well while ian looks into the
true value of horse human on the market
today
it fluctuates like gold you know it's a
commodity
it is a commodity as you well know
you know david dobrik's been a hot topic
of conversation on this podcast
and um he recently had by the way i know
a lot of people don't want to hear me
talk about that
i'm going to talk about it i think it's
fascinating i think it's incredible that
somebody can get away with what he's
like with assaulting someone like that
um on video and admitting to it and
still be like the jewel of the world he
was just number one
so like you're just gonna have to endure
it because i think it's fascinating
it's not gonna be the whole episode but
we're gonna talk a little bit
fascinating i found it really
fascinating
um he can't keep getting away with it
[Laughter]
uh he was number one trending in the usa
with his new app
dyspo
youtube so i don't i don't know if it's
just a matter of people aren't aware or
nobody gives a [ __ ] i truly honestly
think that
with what david has done to seth
and james basically has james been
cancelled since the revelation that he
was like exchanging nudes with the 16
year old it does seem like he's getting
quite a lot of backlash and
uh also uh we mentioned it on frenemies
the other day but the
the main accuser from the other day went
to the police yeah so i mean
if he really did that oh no oh do we
have that update can you show me that
photo
that so the guy who came out against
james who by the way he was like
i saw him talking about how he was going
to delete all of his social media
because he's being harassed by his fans
so hardcore
of course um oh the accuser is yeah the
accuser
is uh because everyone says he's a clown
chaser you can't ever accuse anyone of
anything online if they're famous
without being a clown chaser like okay
sister gotta get that clown
that's like saying anyone who's famous
could never do anything wrong
i gotta get that clout pill
um horse semen is said to be i need that
clout
speaking of james charles horse semen is
said to be
the most expensive semen in the world
and the most expensive liquid in the
world
so this is a gallon [ __ ] this
guy you sell it by the gallon
i mean have you seen a horse that's
literally coming buckets
depending on the stallion horsiem is one
of the most expensive liquids on the
planet
a gallon of gold metal winning big star
semen wow say that again
that sure does look like i mean 4.7
million is way more than the uh
horseshoe but that's a gallon i'm
talking you know what i'm saying you
gotta you gotta get it down like how
much is that per
like how much scorpion jizz are you for
you know that's not a lot of liquid all
right but still
a gallon bro that like go to the grocery
store a gallon that's a whole lot
a gallon of gold medal winning big star
semen it sounds like an award it's an
award-winning semen it sounds like a
beer
that you know get yourself
a cool refreshing gallon of gold star
winning big star seamen crack open a
cool one today
i love that
anyway so you think james is because he
was like tweeting i don't know what's
going on with james but i haven't heard
of anything
like substantial happening but might the
only comment the guy's making uh actual
like if you went to the police and doing
criminal charges you know that might
take a while
yeah yeah yeah no i'm just wondering
like
well i have to i guess we'll have to see
like if he's getting
partners and sponsors and stuff if
anyone deserves to be canceled it's
honestly james charles at this point
because he's proven that he's actually
a menace to society like he is not he's
not responsible enough to have a fan
base
he continues to prey on children and
even in his apology
he accused the six general kid excuse me
i'll get the [ __ ] disgust out of my
body
he accuses the six-year-old kid of
having ulterior motives when james is
the one that went out of his way to
follow him
and he said he doesn't pledge to stop he
pledges to check
ids in the future when flirting with
people online
that is so true like that
that piece alone proves how sick
in the head he is he can't keep getting
away with it
exactly so i don't know
but i really truly think that um people
just don't care about male victims i
really think
that me too just washed over the male
victims nobody gives a [ __ ]
when it's a male it really doesn't
i mean here there's an update apparently
about james charles oh yeah this is
thank you
this is the guy who made the recent
video who said he was 16.
oh but he says i've been harassed so
much in my life
this here i'll just read it i've never
been harassed so much in my life this is
exactly why i didn't want to talk about
my james
charles story the disgusting threats and
comments i've been receiving for simply
sharing an experience i have aren't
saying i'm probably going to delete my
social media soon
yeah that's why that's why people don't
come forward against people like
david dobrik or james charles especially
david
dobrik who's like [ __ ] untouchable
god and seth seth is still getting [ __ ]
on like we're going to talk about that
later but
um i have a bunch of comments from
people on the subreddit because i'm
wondering how people rationalize this
and it's pretty crazy anyway
so david has this app dyspo which is as
i think abu said it's like a edgy
instagram
you take a photo you can't [ __ ] see
it
until tomorrow that's the idea and you
can't edit it
you can't edit it you cannot you can't
see it until tomorrow
you wake up right
you said it what you said that was like
the same as casey's idea for what was
case
beam um it was sort of similar in the
way that
i mean i didn't have beam but i believe
beam was you would just hold it up
against your chest and it would record
whatever you showed and you couldn't
edit it it would just go up
to like it's like snapchat but except
you can't edit it
influencers can sell any [ __ ] thing i
swear to god like peace and love to
casey but that is such a dumb idea
like you have to hold it to your chest i
mean who's who's i
you know it's easy to say that maybe you
know what i mean well
clearly i am right in hindsight because
that did not pick up
but it's easy to sit here and be like
dude suppose [ __ ] dumb because you
never know
people probably said that about facebook
you know what i mean but it sounds dumb
i just feel like in this day and age
when everybody's so image obsessed and
and airbrushing every photo
and wanting to look perfect or whatever
trying to go against the grain on that
and have a product where you can't edit
a photo
and you can't even see it till the next
day is just so
against like what people value
i mean maybe people will like the
novelty of that but
yeah it just seems like it's going to
crash and burn well you'll be
interested to know dan that it's already
valued at 200 million dollars according
to axios despite
literally not existing that's what i'm
saying like
the whole app industry and invest
capital adventures and all these
idiots such a bubble i don't i
don't know that it's a bubble it's just
a bunch of like these people it seems
exactly like in the late 90s with the
the dot-com burst the same the same
exact
well with influencers though you
actually command
you command users it's like more than
just an idea and you come with a dumb
idea with a lot of people
using it i guess that's true apparently
they've raised 20 million dollars in
investments and it's
already valued at 200 million which just
cracks me the [ __ ] up dude
garbage despite having no revenue and
not even existing
it's worth 200 million so dyspo allows
you
you cannot cut photos edit them or add
filters stickers or
anything and they cannot even be
published instantly
or whenever the user elects but they are
revealed to 9am the next day
so it's like going back to getting a
disposable camera
developed essentially yeah the i think i
just
oh that's what the dyspo is yeah i mean
having a disposable camera has got to be
way more fun
like just get that there's there's the
tactile experience
exactly yeah yeah which by the way those
came back into style you can get like
modern day disposable or polaroids i
mean
and either use those all the time
they're really fun i love using those
like
modern day polaroids polaroids only take
like a minute to develop though yeah
dude
and dyspo photos are shown as they are
and you cannot add a caption to explain
what is happening
these are published separately or in
roles that can be shared
so there's a commercial so here's the
commercial
that was trending i'll play for you guys
[Laughter]
oh so he's so sad
he's got such great memories now funnily
enough
oh
[Music]
what he's looking at pictures of
seth and a gorilla and jason and like
blackface what the hell
these are the memories you cherish david
after all these years
[Music]
[Laughter]
these are the photos you saved of
everything trisha crying and you bowling
big nick
oh my goodness
[Music]
so that was so wow pretty compelling
stuff i'm sold
i'm downloading the app right now you
can't it's invite only
yeah i got an invite
[Music]
it's funny because he's holding the
polaroids but he's not
but
[Music]
but he's selling disposable like you see
what i'm saying
oh wait no those are developed yeah yeah
never mind
okay these are the photos he chose to
save i can't believe it
look at this these are your good
memories david that's twisted bro
that is not okay
hmm brings a tear to your eye
yeah ah the the memories
yeah so he still hasn't answered for
this which is crazy
we need to start like a countdown i feel
like this reveal
uh actually gives somewhat of an
explanation for why he hasn't addressed
this because
if this was on the horizon having a big
scandal right before he launches his
giant app it's probably the last thing
he wanted so
one billion you know i had no idea this
app was was going on
but um apparently you know who what's
really dis
disposable um everybody in david's life
like big nick seth all of his friends
jason once he gets in trouble for
for assaulting seth
this it's perfectly uh it's perfect that
he calls his app disposable because
that's how he sees everybody
trisha for example
[Music]
yeah there was there was memes on tick
tocks about um
oh i'm gonna mute it david did this
transformation into being old
and uh this was a pretty good tick tock
here
looks a lot like uh someone else we know
huh no
[Music]
interesting
that's [ __ ] brutal right
i'm almost done with david thing but
let's go over to david's
subreddit because i was wondering like
when you have evidence
of this
assault on camera and him talking about
it in great detail i was racially
motivated and
you know the great lengths he went and
that he knew it would
humiliate him so i went to a subreddit i
saw this help me understand i'm
genuinely confused for the support for
david right now
top comment all there is to understand
is that trisha is still about her and h3
is an insecure sellout
everyone should question if they're
exploiting seth's story and maybe focus
a bit more on the source of all this
drama
she said herself if j her and jason
broke up she would destroy them
i mean i don't understand that rational
first of all first of all
sellout insecure
maybe insecure maybe but yeah
come on didn't think which one i wanted
to accept
sell out fine insecure also fine
i mean david he's on camera it's not
there's no source of the story
it's seth's story seth is the source of
the story
so here's another one this shit's crazy
if ethan doesn't use david's name how
else is he going to afford the new car
he got
this is the most money this guy's
probably made
come on but this is the this is the
rationale people have it's just
it's all about making money
getting views
one that just sidesteps the actual
criticism fully it's just
yeah attack the the it's just the person
who's talking about it rather than
the argument i fully support anyone who
actually suffers from racism
discrimination or abuse
however this sexual assault allegation
is ridiculously toxic borders on
insanity
i'm sorry to the new generation of
internet kids but the same age as
but being the same age as david and i
could truly say how pg the internet has
become the last three years
seriously you can't even like
do the yeah back when i was a kid dude
the internet was like
homeless people fighting each other so
maybe it's better that it's been cleaned
up a little bit
that was like what we used to watch and
like uh people being
decapitated and [ __ ] rotten.com
rotten.com man that website is not
[ __ ] okay
jesus christ bro was that website taken
off the internet or what
i don't want to check
it probably still exists oh god i don't
really want to type that url in there go
someone type that in and see what's
there i'm on it tell me what you see
describe it
i don't know what what's wrong with
people like why would you go there
jesus well it sounds like this person's
argument is that
these kind of joke like it's only
continue to read
jokes that were socially acceptable
three years ago and get canceled for not
boys [ __ ] around with each other and
that's what we do david's biggest
mistake was thinking everyone around him
was his friend
because you can do those things with
friends and it'd be funny not abusive
big nick said repeatedly dave paul okay
so big nick said david apologized and he
accepted it the difference that you're
missing again because i don't think
you're actually watching what we're
doing you're just looking at face value
seth told him he was not okay with it
and they didn't want it out there
and then when david asked if he could do
it again to seth said
insisted over and over that no he could
not do it to him again
and cut the small part where he said
it's okay you're also ignoring the part
where david literally says it was
racially motivated because he knew
homosexuality isn't
accepted in the african-american
community
so like this is not boys will be boys
dude
oh rotten's not up thank god i think
[ __ ] god that website's not online
today
she's i mean all that shit's still out
there obviously but
i don't know where to find it anymore
thank god
bro trust me you don't you don't want
kids going to ryan.com man that
shouldn't work
like middle school awful no wonder our
generation's so
[ __ ] we're all grown up on rotten.com
if you guys are wondering was there it
was just like the most
horrific [ __ ] it was just like
an imgur people before videos
yeah i guess there were videos yeah yeah
people blowing their brains out
people crushed by utilization it's just
the worst [ __ ]
possible you remember the pain olympics
bro
oh i wish i didn't yo olympics
yo so we've all so no wonder we're all
[ __ ] in the head because we all saw
this video called the bme pain olympics
where you watch a guy take like a
hatchet and [ __ ] hack his dick and
balls off bro
i'm telling you
you don't need to go through life saying
this and yet we all did
was that real though it looked real man
i've heard people always go i think
people try to convince themselves it's
fake
because you just can't stomach that
knowing it's real
so there's been a lot of conjecture as
it reels it fake it looked real as [ __ ]
it looked real as a mother they had some
real stuff
they had cartel videos but they're i
mean the whole video the pain olympics
was like all about genital mutilation
of dudes doing it to themselves right
yeah hammers through it and [ __ ]
i saw this one video on uh e-fucked
which is a total crap shoot because
e-fuck can be fun until it's not fun
anymore
me and either were watching it one day
just i don't know we were bored
and it was all fun and games because
usually it's like weird just
off-beat [ __ ] until one time we click we
clicked the video
it was a dude a girl in a stiletto step
on stepping on a dude's dick with the
pointy part and the
pointy part broke through his [ __ ] oh
i've seen that one
and then i closed he [ __ ] and never
went back i literally couldn't get that
image out of my head for a while i just
felt the stiletto going through my [ __ ]
okay so god yeah that's horrible
um yeah so uh doing a little bit of
research so the the pain olympics thing
um that the event and a lot of those
videos are real
the one that you're talking about though
where he fully chops his dick um that
one is a hoax apparently
how do you know you know that's proven
uh
i'm just going off of an article yeah i
mean i i i i've read that i don't know i
i hope that's true i hope it's true
i think there's a lot of people know
what we're talking about a lot of people
who don't
but man oh man that was some wild [ __ ]
don't recommend
seeking it out if you haven't was that
where like two girls one cup was
like on those types of weddings two
girls one cup had its own website i
believe it was literally two girls
onecup.com
yes yes what is the origin of two girl
one cup was that really from some porno
or was that just like a spectacle
no man it was like a snuff film it was
about it's not a
snuff film bro snuff is like when you
die isn't it uh
isn't it snuff film like when you killed
them and then one of the one of the
women did die
from eating the eating the poople
yeah no she actually did die yeah you're
bullshitting you gotta
google it google it well in that case it
is a snuff film no but that can't be
true zack
that's what it was a brazilian film one
of them
now sells ice cream and the other passed
away
oh we gotta go buy ice cream for her no
if you haven't seen it the reason that's
so horrible is it it
it looks like there's some poo poo that
looks like ice cream at one point
well so i mean everybody's seen two
girls one cup but there's this really
beautiful music and then these girls
there's like a oh my god dude so there's
like a dude
there's a doo doo and an ice cream cone
right and they eat it
or yeah you see the dude pooping right
or girl poops
yes yes girl poops on ice cream and then
they eat it and then they puke it out
right and then they look like really
beautiful music plays
i'm trying to see except eating it
two girls one cup has a wikipedia page
so i'm i'm
scanning through it real quick to see if
uh girl really died
that was some good [ __ ] back then boy
hungry oh here's the movies from hungry
[ __ ] yeah
hungry [ __ ] i'll say apparently it
was a it was a
that video was a trailer that was the
trailer for hungry [ __ ] so
that's good if that's just the trailer i
can't even imagine how bad the actual
movie is
i never really guessed it
bro there's no way the girl died i don't
see any deaths involved
that's 62 minutes of pure [ __ ] eating
fun
62 minutes bro and then they eat their
poo poo i'm not saying anything about
them dying why would she die she's a pro
she's a [ __ ] eating pro
i remember reading an article that one
of them did pass away
some parents just made this [ __ ] up so
kids don't eat their own [ __ ]
yeah yeah i don't i don't think poo poo
eating the poo poo is deadly
well you can though yeah
they're pros though they know what
they're doing
only trained professionals
oh what the [ __ ] we're talking about
david dobrik
david epstein the other person is poo
pooing
hey people pay to see that i don't know
what to tell you buddy
yeah not only is david um not responding
he continues to remove
any clip like you remember we did like a
reaction video
where i was making fun of the reactors
because i didn't say anything and i was
watching the original video
well he blocked that one wow they're
going after
every piece of evidence that this video
existed
except me of course mine is still up i'm
kind of of
two minds of that because i mean
obviously he's motivated by trying to
cover it up but
but also it probably shouldn't be on the
internet like it's a [ __ ] up video
yeah but that's not why he's removing it
i agree but like it's probably good that
it's not readily available i just think
i just think it's telling that he's
going after all these little
breadcrumbs trying to erase it from the
internet
why don't you just acknowledge it bro if
you're gonna go around blocking it just
acknowledge that it happened
you know
what'd you say ian oh
ian or i mean zach this is obviously a
joke dude
it says latifah the co-star
died of dysentery three days after
filming the now iconic clip that's
obviously a joke
where'd you read that i guess from where
ian sent it from
where'd you send it from ian no i didn't
send it i
i was looking it up but i i'm seeing
that posted on places like i
funny and stuff like that is that your
source zack
no i remember your time i funny
i remember you got that on i funny what
zach i find
i thought he's been around for a while
that's where i get all my jokes
hey zach what's with the police sharer
you what are you
following my lead are you is this a
solidarity thing what's going on with
the bleached chair
i i mean i'm the golden boy and
i have to out do a b with simpness
so you follow my you just followed me
yeah
it's like a ryan michael scott situation
yeah right
wait i guess yeah actually it's reversed
yeah never mind
okay looks pretty good i like it it's a
little
it's still got some just looked like
yeah
um i bleached it two times and
added a blonde color to it and it
[ __ ] burned the [ __ ] out of my scalp
can we get some gorilla glue on there
yeah
for a rolex yeah
i think it looks good the color that it
is though
oh this is my favorite david update you
guys this is another post
i found on a subreddit while i was just
looking at people defending him
yo i won the david dobrik 25 cent puzzle
but i'm it's asking for bank info is it
safe
or is it worth 25 cents so that
dude that means that 95 of the people
buying this puzzle and winning
25 cents are not even getting their
prize because they are making you put in
your [ __ ]
bank info to receive 25 cents who the
[ __ ] gonna do that
also most of the kids buying this are
kids they don't have bank accounts you
know what i mean
that's a good point wow so the majority
of these prizes probably 95
is not even being paid the [ __ ] out by
david dobrik
this has one point this is literally
what's going on
the fact that even he could get away
with this puzzle thing baffles me
i don't think many people could get away
with this puzzle thing and be
allowed by people like casey neistat and
logan paul as
being this genius entrepreneur it's
funny that his fan was calling you a
sellout
i know people always say i'm a seller i
don't know why you're not selling
[ __ ] lotteries to children and
i mean am i trying to make a living yes
but i consider all the money i've made
like legitimate i mean i'm not [ __ ]
putting poison in baby food or anything
i mean what makes me a sellout i don't
know
i think making i'm disgusting i'm gonna
kill you i'm gonna be 200
oh now that's a sell-off
yo exactly david dobrik is making a
puzzle piece
where you have to put your bank info in
to get 25 cents out
that's selling out yeah but everyone
says he's a genius businessman so i
don't know what the [ __ ] is this
like to me growing up people would call
like
a band to sell out if they like went
mainstream and
you know signed to a major label and
changed their stuff sell their could
sell their songs
right yeah like that's selling out like
what what have what have you done
maybe here's what selling out would be
for me let me think
i think me going let's say
and what's selling out for me what would
be selling it'd be like selling the h3
brand
to an m to mtv to make a
reality show that you're not even in and
it's that'd be good
or something you know what i mean like
that's selling now or like me doing a
maybe me doing like a a documentary now
with shane or something
that would be that would be something
like that or doing like let's say
doing that oh you know would be selling
out joining the vlog squad
that would be [ __ ] selling out for
sure
yeah a little a little skeptical uh
i'm here david
he actually might actually have my
number no i don't think so
anyway uh so that's that i'm done
everybody [ __ ] be happy ethan's done
talking about david
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you peace and
love
[Applause]
um a plastic surgeon performed surgery
during a zoom court appearance
this mother this these by the way
plastic surgeons are not reputable
people
i just distrust genera in general
plastic surgeons some are
you kidding me don't don't blanket
dismiss because lots of plastics are
yeah you do plastic surgery for like
people that get burned horribly or
disappeared in some way
and like there's definitely legit
plastic surgeons what about one dude
a lot of them a lot of them are hacks
though for sure
but i feel okay all right maybe this guy
this guy is
well what do you think of so this
[ __ ] i'll just play the video so
uh can everybody hear me officer
officer monroe mr green elizabeth
ramirez uh is she part of this case
yes oh people are just coming in
what i'm looking at is scott douglas
green's case case number 20 tr095795
i believe officer monroe is present on
this case as well
so unless i'm mistaken i'm seeing a
defendant that's in the middle of an
operating room
appearing to be actively engaged in
providing services to a patient
is that correct mr green yes sir or
what i should i say dr green but i don't
know that's
um i do not feel comfortable uh for the
welfare of a patient
if you're in the process of operating
that i would put on a trial
notwithstanding the fact that the
officer is here today
i have another i have another surgeon
right here who's doing the surgery with
me so i can stand here and allow them to
do the surgery also
not at all i'm i i don't think so i
don't think that's appropriate i think
we're going to have i'm going to come up
with a different date
when you're not actively involved or
participating in
attending to the needs of a patient um
let me see if i can get it yeah this is
the craziest [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this man
what is wrong with this man
i'm here live that's not i'm not a cat
i mean imagine being that patient you
know what i mean you wake up and you're
like wait i was getting
my tits enlarged on february 28th
[Music]
it reminds me we had a the booty doctor
there was uh there was a doctor who was
filming patients
unbeknownst when he was like operating
on their butts to make him bigger
and she was dancing it was a woman right
and she she was like
making like tick-tock dance videos while
operating on people
yeah yeah that ruled
[Applause]
there's a lot but i'm saying a lot of
doctors and i think dentists who are
kind of on the radar
they're on notice you got people like
jimmy lee out there
operating on people scott greene for
example he's doing operating on people
i mean from all accounts jimmy is a
great dentist though right
been very successful yeah he's good at
what he does apparently the man knows
teeth
he knows teeth comedy a little shaky
ah man what a [ __ ] idiot
this is so stupid what does did he just
forget i wonder
like i was just wondering like how did
this happen did he forget he had a court
case
and he just opened up zoom real fast in
the middle of
yeah [ __ ] he double booked
do we know what uh what the the case was
about was it just
was it something really important i mean
probably not considering the judge was
just like
he's just like fighting a speeding
ticket or something that's like
yeah i doubt it was very important
oh my god okay so the golden globes
appear i don't know is the golden globes
a big deal i didn't even know what
happened
apparently it happened like this week
well it was all done remote
so i mean it didn't get as much you know
half the
hype around these award shows is for the
red carpet and all that
nonsense or whatever it's not happening
here watch them care about this [ __ ] you
see but i didn't even know what happened
that's what they did everything over
zoom
and you know the pandemic sucks but all
this
zoom mishaps are great so let's remember
2021 fondly for that at least
because al pacino this is so
amazing is in the virtual audience and
he's just [ __ ] sleeping bro
this is the best thing
i love al pacino i just i guess to be
fair he's
he's like what he's probably in his 80s
now yeah and i mean it's the golden
globes yeah
what do you want him to do sit there for
two hours he's looking fly as hell
though and he's got that
goddamn he's got that
really nice like
mid mid life crisis are not it's like
just a middle-aged woman's haircut
really
it's almost like a hillary clinton which
is awesome here
they did him dirty bro they could have
panned to somebody else
they're like i'll sleep and [ __ ] get
his ass
you broke my heart listen
golden globes camera operator i know it
was you
god you had brad pitt on my left
leonardo dicaprio above me
yeah you chose to bend to me frozen
cough during a nap
you've broken my heart fredo
you broke my heart
but you've never been tired i'm a 85
year old man
and you been over to me what did i do to
deserve this disrespect al pacino
i know it was you fredo and now
everybody's goofing on me on
for my hair that looks like a [ __ ]
fishbowl
i don't know what's wrong with white
people making fun of his hair i like his
hair
i think it looks good i'm not even
saying that
i saw people were clowning on it on his
hair yeah
yeah i don't know seems fine
80 years old man he looks great for 80.
let's see he won
he was nominated for some show i've
never heard of on amazon prime call
hunters i don't know what the [ __ ] that
is
that was that uh isn't it about nazi
hunters a great show
it really is oh i was excited about that
but i saw it was getting bad reviews so
i just skipped it
uh it has a 64 on rotten tomatoes not
great well he didn't win but it got a
golden globe nomination
he's real excited about that clearly so
so did uh
so did sia right so exactly see he got
two nominations
yeah i heard two girls one cup was even
nominated for cinematography
right yeah classic film an achievement
achievement pacino's reps did not
immediately return
requests for comment hmm i mean what's
there to say
we're waiting for comment you guys owe
us an explanation
not only did pacino's nap make waves in
their annual show he also got fleck for
his wild hairstyle yeah i don't get that
i think his hair is fly
i think he's 80 years old and he looks
[ __ ] great
the man after all he's done for us
deserves a nap i'm not really seeing
i'm not seeing the hair thing what's the
what's the issue
oh this was also great
daniel for sure he does
[Applause]
what's my name duncancino oh so here by
the way
jared leto you could tell he's so pissed
he didn't win look at him
what the [ __ ] was jared leto nominated
for
look at jared leto he's so angry
what's in his hand he's trying to do a
popper
yo look at that he's so pissed bro
you left me in a black hole of rage and
confusion
[Laughter]
bill murray was in something i'm so
behind
anyway here's his acceptance we just got
hyped
here yeah his mic is muted and the hosts
are just saying i wish i could hear
and they don't know what to do
as you can see we unfortunately have a
bad connection
we apologize for that the connection's
fine and send
all of our damn
they're like peace out he's probably at
home still giving the speech you know
what i mean
yeah he is this on
is this on all right cool
all right who cares
leto you're right leto looked furious
he's so pissed let me do this
what was he even nominated for what is
he doing daniel kaluuya
best supporting actor in a motion
picture for
uh his performance into little things a
drama
[Music]
i need a machine gun
that's interestingly that's the name of
uh
what are you gonna say you know what i'm
gonna say
yo this next one comes from snoop dogg
who apparently is not smoking enough
weed because he rages like a [ __ ] 12
year old on twitch over like madden
i kind of i gotta be honest with you
like i'm not gonna
i've not one to say i haven't raged at
playing video games before
but i feel like it's not i don't like
seeing snoop do it
you know what i mean he's supposed to be
the chill cool dad
and he gets so angry
he's so angry he's just [ __ ] madden
bro and you're like 60.
look at him he's fuming
[Music]
[ __ ] madden football snoop dogg
so he storms off in a rage
and apparently he left this stream going
for like 12 hours
where people just hung out in the chat
and then he came back in the morning 12
hours later and turned it off
they just pieced that thing sucks
i don't know do you know what i mean
like it's just it makes me
had a heated gamer moment i don't like
seeing snoop dogg like that
it's not the vibe that i want from him
yeah
yeah yeah you're right he's uh do you
think he maybe he had too much indiga
not enough
sativa i don't know what i'm talking
about that's just like weed talk
[Laughter]
i feel like the weed talk is always so
stupid people get so into weed like
no no no no no your problem is that you
just you need to smoke sativa
i i've smoked a lot of weed in my life
and i gotta tell you it's
it's all the same thank you dan somebody
finally [ __ ]
says it there's no i go can you really
tell the different indica and sativa oh
yeah bro
oh it's way more different oh you want
the body high you got to do the indica
bro but i was like dude i don't know
about you but no matter what i smoke i
feel like
[ __ ] paranoid and regretful that i
ever did it
yep everybody i've ever had i don't feel
that way but um
i i think yeah people overstate greatly
the uh
the variance and impact of bro
bubble gum sherman dumping dupin
snooping that should have put you right
to sleep
i mean certainly different weed has
different potency
like some is stronger than others like
that's real but um
as far as you know the intricacies of
what this specific strain is going to do
this to you versus this
it's pretty bogus wake up it's pretty
bogus
yeah i just don't like seeing snoop like
this he's supposed to be the cool
i mean this is not a good ad for weed
look at this [ __ ]
you know what i mean he didn't smoke it
up
like i can't remember the last time i
was that mad at anything
you've been playing all the souls games
and you haven't uh you know rage quit
not that mad not that bad not that good
live
[ __ ] it he's playing competitive online
though that does that does amp up the uh
dude he's a grown-ass man who's his
blood is half with thc
yeah he's so bad
how about when you were a teenager like
yeah
yeah i mean i've raged as a child as a
kid you know yeah
just don't take video games that
seriously anymore yeah same
as a teenager for sure playing uh
warcraft three starcraft
[ __ ] thing sucks you're pretty mad
i be i beat all the games i beat
bloodborne i beat all the dark souls i'm
out
[ __ ] done oh you beat bloodborne oh
nice i didn't i could be honest i liked
bloodborne but
the ending was bizarre like i got the
true ending where you
kill the moon presence and spoil the
alert
for six-year-old whatever yeah it
doesn't make any sense it's like oh you
become a little worm it's like i don't
get it how do you become a worm by
killing the moon presence
stupid that's the blood of god i didn't
like it
you want to explain it to me dan cause
you seem obsessed with like you got like
two hours
seriously well they like don't show
something i kill the moon presence and
then i'm a maggot like growing up as a
old i get it
you ascended you're you're you're uh
you're a great one now you're a god
stupid the gods are [ __ ] in that game
you kill them so easy by the way
who wants to be a god the hunter is way
more powerful true that's true
death anyway so that's snoop dogg
next up we've got wendy who knew that
old wendy williams and notice i say
windy
not wendy because she that's her farting
and i
i know many of you who are new to the
show may not realize but that is a real
fart zack go ahead
[Music]
that's her fart isolated
and turned up i forgot that that one was
windy not pitched or anything
no that's straight up wendy williams
passing gas on her show
no it was a cup uh being moved across
the table that was her
explanation i got to pull that up wendy
williams because i gotta
actually that clip i specifically
remember
goddess claimed oh for real yeah they're
they're catching that wendy farting clip
the wendy williams show in general
is one of the most prolific claimers of
anything we've ever watched on the show
like any time we've ever done anything
with women yo they're cashing
on that fart money bro for money yeah
well she did in fact they claimed this
once just for using a sound bite from
their show
of the the the audience doing the woo
what yeah that got us a claim
[ __ ] you wendy anyway i don't like wendy
williams
i think she's a really obnoxious person
and um her show's just bizarre frankly
because like the women they're just
they're way too involved in the show
then she comes out and they'll go what
what it's just it's just so bizarre and
you know
so wendy williams is of course on top of
all of her great qualities that i love
an anti-vaxxer and she went on dr
oz show and
uh i guess good for dr oz he's out there
he's showing himself getting his vac his
covet shot he's trying to you know
drum up support for it because there's a
lot of dumb dumbs out there who don't
want to get it
peace and love peace and love um
and she's straight up he she says
straight up to dr oz
i'm not getting it i don't trust it
let's watch
so are you planning on getting your
vaccine
no no no you don't have it on the screen
oh [ __ ] i'm such an idiot sometimes i
just sit here and watch on my laptop and
forget i'm doing a show
by the way he's like that's not going as
you planned dr
oz he's trying to drum up support and
then he brings on some idiot anti-vaxxer
he goes so when are you getting your
shot i'm not
hottest topic in medicine right now the
covert vaccine
i just got vaccinated uh i did okay
i didn't have any issues there i am
noticing the huge biceps muscles the
pectoralis by the way
mimi you know you're a very sexy man
so are you planning on getting your
backseat
no no brave
i don't trust it yo it's the same vibe
that i get from joe rogan and elon musk
it's just like in the face
in the face of nobody willing to speak
the truth i will stand up and say
no i will not get the covet vaccine she
doesn't trust it
girl what haven't you injected in your
body i mean with peace and love you have
like a gallon of botox in your [ __ ]
face and you're afraid of a covet shot
that is the dumbest
rationale ever you've ejected everything
in the kitchen and
in the bathroom sink and [ __ ] into
your face lips
eyelash eyebrows and forehead and you
won't get a covet vaccination
i mean i've seen you faint like on stage
if anyone needs it it's you
we need to protect wendy williams she
can't even control her own bowels
she's on stage farting and passing gas
and [ __ ]
god damn i've never gotten the flu shot
either though and you and i have talked
about that
yeah well it's not the flu shot it's a
[ __ ] pandemic dude
how are people so miseducated and she
thinks she's being so woke and edgy
the doctors on my team talk to me about
wendy we'll get the flu shot
i've never had the flu i'm not getting a
flu shot i very rarely get a cold i
never have headaches
i don't take an aspirin because i feel
my heart
or something like that i'm not getting
no i don't trust it there i said it
don't what do you mean you don't trust
it there i said it
now hand me that botox needle
by the way botox is like the most uh
toxic
fact checkmate but botox the reason it
works is because it's like the most
toxic poison known
to humankind and they put like so little
of it in you
that it it causes that reaction in your
skin i don't know about it being
the most but but yeah i mean it is a i
mean it's like
a dead toxin botox stands for toxin yes
you're
injecting a toxin i don't trust it
oh here we go apparently there's there's
like seven or eight different types of
botox so
maybe maybe one of them is uh i don't
trust it there i said it
now hand me those bags of now hand me
those bags of jelly and insert it in my
ass
and [ __ ] give me 20 syringes of botox
and mutilate my face i mean listen
there's no i'm not trying to shame her
for getting plastic surgery but if
you're gonna sit here and give
misinformation on kovitz shots and you
don't trust it i mean what the [ __ ] do
you trust you trust
everything about this why i uh i'm sorry
for doubting you
uh botulium oh bolt how the [ __ ] you say
that
botox are the most poisonous proteins
known
you got it hey i'm right about something
this is a big moment for me you guys
can i give an acceptance speech here
please give me some inspirational
guys i'd like to thank my extensive
knowledge
with for my upbringing the estimated
human lethal dose
of type a is one to two
uh nanograms exactly it's so little
it is so toxic and poisonous that they
put like the
almost like it's such a tiny amount
she's like past that [ __ ] by
pass that pass that that's really
something i knew it was poisonous but
not
not that poisonous yeah it is like
insanely toxic
past that [ __ ] when do you pass it in
world war
ii the us army was researching using it
as a
chemical weapon you pass that i trust
that i want that in my face
pass it over here
i mean obviously lots of people use
botox lots of people done covered
shots right yeah no millions and
millions
she should definitely eat it well
researched hey
the drug is under development for
treatment of premature ejaculation
botox yeah oh put that right my [ __ ]
take whatever you got
to treat my [ __ ] oh we got something we
got uh logan paul news what is this
he wrote some kind of cringe like no
little intellectual poem
he wrote a poem and posted it logan paul
declared he's
done with the hollywood lifestyle and
pseudo-intellectual poem that could have
been summarized three words people grow
up
people grow up oh yeah bro
people grow up now i'm dealing with
pokemon cards
can we do a poetry reading yeah i can
get a little slam
poetry music no not give me something
like
sappy you know emotional something
emotional
yes let's see what we got i've grown up
i will no longer be filming dead bodies
and fours
and i will instead be playing pokemon
professionally
as i sit here logan paul 2001
february 28th 1 34 am
as i sit observing the horde
of inevitable i'm already so embarrassed
do you did you forget who you are you're
gonna sit there talking about
the horde of inebriated young hollywood
socialites well let's give him a chance
i mean
he's he's 24 he's he's grown up
it was only a few years ago he was
running around japan like a [ __ ]
basket okay i'll give him another chance
sorry as i
sit observing the horde of inebriated
young
hollywood socialites driven by
temptation
and bad intentions
aka when i turn away from the mirror
i take pleasure in knowing that while a
part of me flourishes in such an
environment
my personal aspirations will not often
lead me
to such crassness
[Music]
the privilege of youth the absence of
responsibility
the free-spirited nature of song and
dance all fleeting
i feel it the venom of adulthood
slowly sinks way into my veins
not the most expensive fluid that is
horsemen we've
determined and with it comes new
passions
like pokemon cards and new habits like
cult like recolonizing puerto rico
i do enjoy it but i cannot
deny the inevitable ending of an era
wow
[Music]
wow
[Applause]
wow wow
oh wait that's jake i'm sorry wow wrong
sound wrong paul
wow jake you better come out with your
own poem now
he sounds like bilbo before going to
rivendell yeah
except he's got to throw his own ass in
the [ __ ] volcano with mount doom
one of the comments says what 16 year
old stoner did he pay to write this
dude you got to be very careful with
poetry because
[Music]
yo listen i stud i majored in poetry
creative writing in college so take it
from me
i would never post any of my poetry
publicly bro trust me on that
because there's a mother freaking
blueberry now that's a line
because you cannot poetry is so personal
right like to actually be a good poet
it's just
bro you it's so hard not to be cringy
it's so it's like impossible not to be
cringy
so hard you know
oh now i'm a starbucks venom by the way
look
listen i think this is a telling line
the venom of adulthood it's like bro you
must really hate your [ __ ] parents
you know what i mean
because he thinks of he thinks adulthood
is venomous it's like
it's not venomous it's just obvious that
you're just gonna have to [ __ ] grow
up dude
maybe it is deep look at me the venom of
adulthood
he's seen what adulthood is through his
parents
and that's he sees as venom sinking into
his hair is falling out greg paul he
sees his daddy lives in an rv and [ __ ]
his fans
that's adulthood that's what he sees as
adulthood it's sinking into his veins
it's inevitable gp coming at you he says
in my veins it comes new passions new
habits like living in an rv and [ __ ]
young girls i do enjoy it though he says
i'd rather speak up and be wrong than be
muffled and be wrong
[ __ ] gp coming at you with those hot
gp should be a poet man
[ __ ] the logan i'd rather speak up and
be wrong
then be muzzled i love her i love that
philosophy
gp really is just like the ultimate
ultimate ohio guy
you know i mean it's really ironic for
him to be like horde of inebriated young
hollywood socialites though i mean dude
it's like
that was like two months ago it's like
okay two months ago now you're writing
poems about it
it's cringe but i mean
there may be some truth in the sentiment
maybe he's just realizing that he can't
be a maverick forever you know dude
maverick these glasses
have changed my life mavericks is
forever
yeah don't i mean i'm just saying you
could share your poem publicly but just
be careful
i don't really give a [ __ ] but thanks
for letting me know
interesting so wendy oh back to wendy i
don't like her she's dumb
i don't trust it when i gotta say i i
disagree i think the vaccine is safe it
was studied carefully and seventy-five
thousand people didn't have any major
issues
about getting it now not seeing big
problems
i gotta say it's worked so well i think
it is a very wise move which is i really
think
you should get the vaccine i think
you'll feel safer if you do as well
so are there questions i can answer for
you
this doesn't respond
i just don't understand how people are
so ignorant still the flu shot
the flu is already everywhere there's
like a billion strains of the flu
and there's a yearly flu shot based on
which strange they think are going to be
relevant you know how they do it they
base it on what's big in australia and
the other
hemisphere during the winter and they
say oh those strains were big so those
are probably the ones that are going to
be big
here australia is our petri dish
and so um so obviously the flu has
already run amok
now the importance of getting the covet
shot windy and uh
i i do know you're listening
[Music]
is so that the [ __ ] covet doesn't
become like the flu and we can actually
kill it now before it has time to have a
billion variations that we can never
stomp it out
so your dumb ass not getting the vaccine
is ensuring that this [ __ ] is going to
last forever
and you know you got to get the shot
dum-dum
hand me that botox i don't trust it
dumbass why do people think it's so
brave not to get the covet shot like
they do it with the max they're just
contrarians i think they just
think i don't get it how you doing
i've never gotten the flu shot either
though and okay [ __ ] that doesn't make
you brave i mean
get the flu shot or not it's not the
same thing if you get the
you not getting the flu shot doesn't
affect the whole world you know what i
mean
that's just you trying to protect
yourself against the flu because we're
not going to eradicate the flu
right but we can eradicate covet
thank you peace and love
okay uh a warning to american diplomats
traveling to china
the u.s has accused china of forcing
american diplomats to take
anal swab tests for covid19
oh yeah when we talk about that yeah
they were developed because they're
developing an anal swab test because
apparently koval
lasts longer in your butthole than your
uh this is sick
you're uh whatever do you remember the
video
of like the demonstration that's awesome
bro
the us has accused china of making
american diplomats take anal swabs
before backtracking after the us
complained
i love this has become like a um
a whole diplomacy crisis
look there china's being careful man you
see if you've got a drop trowel and get
your butt all swabbed that's
that's what you got to do you know one
of the things they do is called
eno leaking i'm gonna i'm gonna make you
guys get your [ __ ] swabs once you go
back to the office
i wonder if that's legal uh drop trial
bruh
let me swap that ring
crazy i'll do it if you do it first yeah
i wonder if there i don't even know if
you can get that test in the us i would
do it but
i don't think the technology has reached
here yet
a state department representative told
advice on wednesday the us had
complained to china
when it learned that some members had
been made
to get a cotton swab right up the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
the person added that china told the us
that the tests were given to american
diplomats staff
in error
and that the diplomatic staff members
were supposed to be exempt from the test
which
some parts of china have started using
in a bid for more actually damn they're
actually dude china's actually making
people drop trout
that i feel like that's that's going to
be posing more
health risks than alleviating
you got billions of people dropping
trowel and exposing their bottle to the
earth
to the open air like that what's the
worst gonna happen
dude i heard that when you don't wear
underwear your farts
are more deadly like literally you can
get people sick because your
part your [ __ ] particles float through
the air and you can get sick
where did you hear this exactly you wear
underwear you're worried now
i do wear underwear so why were you so
concerned about that comment
you perked up i mean i'm just you know
looking at her
back check me i don't know where i heard
it she's one of those earlier this
episode you said
eating [ __ ] wouldn't get you sick yeah i
don't know
i i said it was not deadly
i mean i'm still alive do you wear
underwear at home
yes i don't in your room in your parents
house
you're at home right now yeah
i'm full commander already you mean yeah
why not well you when you're home i mean
when you're out yeah you obviously wear
underwear but when you're home like i
don't know you get bunched up dude
cool you've never experienced that
when you're laying in bed and you're
like oh yeah i don't i don't like to
wear underwear in bed usually
but that's not the same thing as walking
around naked your hou your parents house
bruh
i'm not walking around naked i'm wearing
pants okay you just don't wear underwear
right
well i know women take their bra off
like the second they get home i know
that
bra balls yeah man you gotta swing them
free
um
yeah you guys are getting anal swabs for
sure
just to be extra sure because i'm not
[ __ ] wrong with kovid
people like wendy william walking around
if you take it and you know i still
might not take it
uh back on tick tock there's people
who are trying to burn snow they're
saying the snow
from that's falling from the sky
is fake snow
which apparently means there's some kind
of
manhattan sized snow blower
that's i mean i don't know how exactly
they figured this out
our government and bill gates thank you
bill gates
for trying to [ __ ] trick us that this
is real snow
you'll see it's not melting
and it's going to burn snow don't burn
snow [ __ ] melts no water no dripping
no nothing
she understands how if i put this [ __ ]
in the microwave it's gonna start
sparking
because there's metal mixed in it so you
see that
no way no matter i love how gullible
this guy is no
[ __ ] way trying to get our freedom
for the world
it's just burning put it closer
what the hell see it does look like it's
melting doesn't it i'm in upstate new
york
this is what's on my car this is
supposed to be oh is this the same woman
or
they're straight lines all the same
movements
oh there's a whole fake snow movement
bro
there's so there's snow truthers now out
there
holy god how we expect how we can expect
people to
if we can't even explain to wendy
williams how vaccines work
we have no hope for the world when
people out there thinking snow is fake
this is not snowflakes what the heck is
going on
you figured it out you cracked the case
let's go find some snaps this is
insane you guys got a snowball here we
go
highest setting hot
give it a second no drip
give it a moment
it's called sublimation it's basically
when a solid skips the liquid form it
goes straight to a gas
stove like high school chemistry they
could just google it instead of all
these experiments
so what is this uh phenomenon they're
just heating it too fast and it goes
straight to ga
it evaporates yeah i forget the
condition
as to what causes it but yeah it's when
it goes straight from a solid to a gas
and skips the liquid phase also
apparently
when snow melts the water is largely
absorbed by the remaining
loosely packed snow this is how snow
cones hold their delicious sugary water
it looks like it's just getting more
dense first of all it's freezing outside
you've got this huge
cold ball of snow that's been out in
freezing temperatures
hitting it with some hot air for a
second isn't going to melt it
you know so people are basically
discovering
a a basic fundamental scientific
issue or just not being patient enough
and uh
it's proof that bill gates is sending
out fake snow for
for what reason we don't know do they
have a theory of why people were faking
snow maybe
well it's cold outside right i mean
they're uh i'm i don't know this but i'm
gonna guess to uh
to convince people that global warming
is real cause i have a feeling that
the snow truthers are probably not uh
how do they fake the temperature
i mean it's [ __ ] freezing clearly i
see her wearing a sweater
it seems like a lot of effort for not
much payoff
it's true yeah i've seen what dan said
about the global warming and i was
i just was trying to get a better grasp
on the uh bill gates thing but i
couldn't find
well he's become he's become the go-to
which okay
so as we've as we've talked about on the
show i'm not necessarily the
biggest bill gates defender or anything
but yeah he's become
just every single conspiracy theory he
he is
the yeah he's perfect he's like god in a
way it's like he's got all the money in
the world
he's like this smart little science guy
you know anything you can explain is
either god or bill gates
also that first video how she's like
look it's burning um
that's just because it's a zippo lighter
it's the butane is the
you know staining it essentially but
also it's not pure water i mean snow
collects [ __ ] dust and particles and
[ __ ]
it's not like that crazy
that too if you take a ball of of
snow and put it in a cup and come back
an hour it's all
dirty and [ __ ] there's so much stuff in
snow explain this
i can't i can't explain it damn it
the snow won't melt this is big snow
the ice cube melts but the snow don't
explain that one mr gates
explain that one now mr gates
yee what's in that covet vaccination
okay another one
a candle it's freezing outside first
snow for all the haters
it's a [ __ ] candle
don't you try to smell a snowball with a
candle
you can put your hand above that thing
for like a whole minute girl don't you
try to melt that
come on don't you try to melt that on a
[ __ ] tiny little candle
not melting so this is the sublimation
probably
although let's be honest that candle is
putting off like
the heat of my butthole come on
not melting
and turning black it's not melting
god woman you need to [ __ ] go on the
internet
but not on facebook jesus is your source
this is your brain on facebook
yeehaw out here to tech in texas the
snow don't mess
they got this snow full with covet
vaccines they don't
melt damn it victory victory
oh god please give us melting snow
we don't want this demonic snow that
don't
melt lord the liberals sent this
snow that don't melt out here to texas
we don't want it lord we like ourselves
know that
you got like a banjo or something like
some kind of like uh deliverance kind of
[ __ ] you could play for me zack
i do but it's uh copyrighted well don't
play it then
wait we had a creepy well creepy banjo
uh thing we played once
oh lord i am afraid of this snow that
don't
melt and i know no not that not creepy
it's more like yeehaw
oh kind of [ __ ] you know what i mean wow
you said deliverance yeah well
deliverance was like the banjo da da
not the creepy [ __ ] all right
this is the kind of music these people
hear in their head when they're trying
to burn snow
lord i know the gay sent us this snow
that don't melt
i know the lord sent us this game snow
that don't
melt lord please save us jesus
jesus made snow that melt i'm doing my
best like kenneth copeland
come on down out of beautiful texas
where
we got no gays no libbers
liberals liberals
and where our snow don't melt from all
those gays having sex
it's god's abomination the unmelting
snow
come on down to texas now you hear
we got no mass no vaccination and our
elderlies are dying
young more space for all of us
texas you ever been to texas never
probably a nice place i kid the texans
come on down to texas where a soft gust
of wind blows out our power grid for two
weeks yeah
based off of the comments when we were
talking about the outage there it seemed
like we had a
we got a sizeable percentage of fans
from texas i mean look it's a really
popular state yeah
i love the texans we love the texans
don't we folks
folks so you know
there's also the liberal side which is
honestly
having just as bad takes
for example keith oberman says
why are we wasting vaccinations on texas
if texas has decided to join the side of
the virus um
it's so it's just it's so this is almost
like a more callous [ __ ] up
take than like opening like i understand
the
i guess he's kidding maybe i don't know
but you understand keith olbermann that
we all need the vaccination
because we got too many wendy williams
and joe rogans and elon musk walking
around we're too [ __ ] woke to take
the vaccination we need as many people
in texas
to get the vaccination i guess
especially if they're opening
especially if they're open we need to
vaccinate them quick
keith
people gotta understand what what he's
not understanding and what the people
and wendy williams they're both not
understanding the same thing it's a
collective issue
we need to not act and the interest of
the individuals we need to act in the
interest of society
keith olbermann
if texas uh i'm gonna do my
uh i make fun of the the texans so i
gotta do my like yankee
impression if the texans uh hm let me
think how to do this
oh if the texans are going to join the
sight of the virus
then why do they deserve our vaccines oh
my
let them die i say
why the texans don't deserve the vaccine
let them die i see
yeah there is douchey as the texans
yeehaw we don't want no vaccine oh
let them die they don't need by the way
texas like a purple state at this point
there's plenty of people there who are
[ __ ]
wanting the vaccine and wearing masks
and doing the right thing you know what
i mean
[Music]
we love our purple states folks
[Music]
if
oh my
what's something bougie and like uh a
yankee would do
if oh he oh you've never tried caviar
oh you drink water instead of champagne
the pate was divine
[Music]
to god in the brand new room
the drawing maybe something like this
like
like uh why does why do they eat
fast food they could buy fresh steak and
uh at whole foods oh my god why
buy a hamburger for 99 cents when you
can buy filet from whole foods
like not understanding concept of like
wealth and poverty
i don't know
why are they in line for food stamps
they could simply
get a job
[Music]
see i don't know if that's see now i'm
getting mixed up that is kind of like a
conservative talking point
we don't like handouts hey oh my we
agree i don't know what i'm doing
i'm losing my mind over here
well anyway keith olbermann shout out
didn't you i remember used to do a bit
like idiot of the week or something well
keith
oberman i hate to break it to you but
you are
douche bag of the day he um he was like
the left uh
uh bill o'reilly for a long time oh was
he oh yeah
and uh he ended up getting fired for
what did he get fired for he ended up
getting fired for doing something
bad look it up real quick
the douchebag of the day is
poor people
[Music]
i don't understand that's all they i
guess that's how people see
anyway michael moore also had a spicy
take we love michael moore he is
he is a liberal sweetheart ooh
[Music]
michael moore's texas we hear you
you didn't want to be a part of our
electrical grid
and now you've removed your basque
mandate and are allowing crowd
large crowds together we hear you
covid is a hoax
so you don't need our precious vaccines
we'll send it to people who are saving
lives by wearing masks again it's the
same dumb [ __ ]
take like bro we need them vaccinated
and by the way it's not your what do you
mean
our vaccine it's not our what it's
everybody's vaccine
what does that mean also everybody in
texas doesn't think it's a hoax like
come on
[Music]
just yeah i mean like you said texas one
of the most populous states like it's
not just a
hive mind
[Music]
it's just so hateful and mean spirited
we need them
vaccinated you're doing the same thing
that wendy williams did we need
everybody vaccinated
i bet you michael moore ripped some fat
[ __ ] farts
you know what i mean
he's a big guy today i will be doing a
documentary on
the conservative brain i don't know
what is michael moore anyway that's it
look
the lip there's the libtards out there
we know i mean just bringing peace and
love and unity
and equality to the equation
everybody needs the vaccine michael
moore
everybody needs the vaccine wendy
[Music]
[Applause]
williams what don't you get
we are all in this together every
[ __ ] body needs the vaccine or we all
lose
you know america's so [ __ ] up because
we spent all this time building up
individualism
and now when we need to pull together as
a society we can't do it
you got the keith's you got the wendy's
[Music]
you need the keith's and the wendy's
come together right now and
wendy if you're more comfortable getting
the shot in your face
we can do that for you as i know you
frequent sight of injection
and keith just shut the [ __ ] up
and michael moore just shut the [ __ ] up
thank you i'm your host ethan klein
preaching love peace and unity
[Music]
wear a [ __ ] mask even if you don't
you have to by law
where because you don't
you don't wear it for yourself you wear
it for the people around you
that's obvious right we all understand
that it's the same thing with the [ __ ]
you don't get the shot for yourself you
get it for the people around you
come on boy you get it it's about other
people you need to be compassionate and
loving and like me
you need to ascend like me
that's it ian do you have anything to
add
i think you hit all the points
thank you attack anything to
beautiful add statement thank you thank
you thank you dan go ahead
please [ __ ] keith olbermann
[ __ ] keith oberman you don't you
specifically [ __ ] keith oberman huh i
[ __ ] hate that guy
really yeah [ __ ] you did you find out
what he was fired for
i was just looking it up uh apparently
it's kind of hush-hush
baby but he had previously gotten in
trouble he had donated some political
candidates which you're not supposed to
do if you're
a news broadcaster it's against the
policies oh for real
you're supposed to be objective you're
supposed to be did you talk about shane
hannity practically is like
a spokesman for the trump campaign well
i mean it's not
that it's illegal but it was against no
[ __ ] changed since then that's for sure
it was against his company's policy at
the time but that wasn't what he got
fired for uh
yeah there's like a strange silence
around his firing
but he was fired from msnbc and he has
not been on a major network
well i have a good [ __ ] guess
probably the same reason everyone else
is getting fired
yeah that's a good point you know what i
mean bye-bye
yeah his uh foil bill o'reilly
got fired for sexual harassment
literally everybody
on everywhere is getting fired for
sexual harassment but we don't know that
we'll do it live
we don't actually know that so cuomo's
going down
[Music]
all riley everybody is going down we're
all going down
keep your hands to yourself people
i'm looking at you zach
[Music]
i just wanted to see your reaction
it is the hair though no it's not the
hair i have that hair what are you
saying about me
yours isn't long
all right that's our show everybody
with peace and love i am signing out i
will see you on friday for
age three after dark live with my
beautiful co-host ila we have a got a
great show planned for you on friday so
we see you then
peace peace and love peace and love
[Music]